Mein Name ist Arthur Honegger.
Acht Jahre lang
waren die USA mein Zuhause.
Arthur Honegger in New York ...
Als Korrespondent bin ich in
dieser Zeit ganz schön rumgekommen.
47 von 50 Bundesstaaten
habe ich besucht.
Und auch heute noch beschäftigt mich
dieses grosse verrückte Land
praktisch nonstop
bei meiner Fernseharbeit.
In dieser Serie will ich nun
mein unbekanntes Amerika entdecken.
Abseits der grossen Politik.
Neue Staaten, neue Menschen,
neue Erfahrungen.
This is my paradise.
Auf den Postkarten
sieht Hawaii jeweils anders aus.
* Hawaiianischer Gesang *
Immerhin, klingen tut's nach Hawaii.
Aber so ein bisschen Regen
hält meine Produzentin Lisa,
Kameramann Sergio und mich nicht auf.
Meine erste Surf-Lektion steht an.
Das Wetterglück kommt auch noch.
Dort hinten ist's blau.
Und Surfen
hat mich schon immer fasziniert.
Aber hey,
da ist doch schon die Sonne.
Schau das an.
Alles blauer Himmel!
* Hawaiianische Musik *
Wellenreiten gehört zu Hawaii
wie die Schmalztolle zu Elvis.
Das Lebensgefühl auf diesen Inseln
ist nirgends so unmittelbar spürbar
wie auf dem Surfbrett.
Das will ich erleben.
Stefan, der uns hier unterstützt,
lebt seit 10 Jahren auf Maui.
Er kennt sich aus,
auch in Sachen Gastfreundschaft.
Thanks. This is nice, thank you!
One for the camera.
Sieht gut aus.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Bist du Dustin?
- Dustin. Hi.
Ich bin Arthur.
- Schön, dich zu kennenzulernen.
Du wirst heute Spass haben.
Das wird grossartig!
Ich hoffe, ja.
- Okay.
Ich bin etwas nervös.
Es ist so viel Wasser.
Ich bin ein Bergmensch, der Ozean
macht mir Angst. Aber okay ...
Ich werde dir helfen.
Du bist in guten Händen.
Wasser ist wirklich nicht
mein Element.
Aber Dustin Tester vertraue ich:
Sie war die erste Frau, die auf Maui
eine Surfschule gegründet hat.
Die wirft so schnell nichts um.
Du bist aus der Schweiz. Kannst du
snowboarden oder Ski fahren?
Snow- und Skateboarding sind
ein wichtiger Teil meines Lebens.
Ich bin quasi auf dem Snowboard
gross geworden.
Das ist super, denn snowboarden,
wakeboarden, skaten,
das geht alles aufs Surfen zurück.
Das wird ein Kinderspiel für dich.
Wenn ich dann mal stehe vielleicht.
Das wird der schwierige Teil.
Arbeite mit der Natur!
Geh mit, nicht gegen den Flow.
Eine gute Lebensregel, oder?
- Go with the flow.
Also, geh mal auf dein Brett!
Zehen zurück.
Eine Armlänge Distanz vom Logo.
Das ist perfekt.
Hast du mal Yoga gemacht?
Wir machen Surf-Yoga.
Hm, nicht, dass es zählen würde.
Mach einen Push-Up.
Hintern in die Luft.
Etwas höher,
damit du deinen vorderen Fuss
zwischen die Hände kriegst.
Etwas weiter nach vorn,
wenn du kannst.
Yes! Setze den hinteren Fuss
und komm hoch.
Gut, du hast es!
Wir sind an Land!
Auf in die Wellen!
Dass Yoga gut fürs Surfen ist,
muss ich meiner Frau erzählen -
sie ist bei uns der Yoga-Crack.
Immerhin:
Beim Yoga bleibt man trocken.
Surfing, das geht nur nass.
Und jetzt paddeln.
Die Knie beugen.
Schau nach vorn. Ja!
Anfängerglück.
Grossartig!
* Hawaiianische Musik *
Great! Great!
That's fun.
Danke, Dustin!
- Du bist super.
Das war hammer.
- Du warst gut!
Ein einzigartiges Gefühl da draussen.
Wie auf Wasser gehen.
Ja, und du bist eins
mit den Elementen.
Alles kommt in einem Moment zusammen.
Richtig. Das hilft dir,
die Fahrt zu geniessen.
Ich freue mich
auf die nächste Lektion am Freitag.
auf deine Fortschritte.
Bevor du es merkst, bist du an der
Nordküste mit 20 Fuss hohen Wellen.
Weiss nicht. Kleine Schritte ...
Dustin jedenfalls glaubt an mich.
Sie gibt mir
ein Brett für Fortgeschrittene mit.
Okay, ich hoffe mal,
ich komme neben dem Dreh zum Üben,
bevor Dustin Ende Woche sehen will,
wie weit ich gekommen bin.
Ich bin fast 4'000 km
vom Festland entfernt,
mitten im Pazifik.
Hawaii ist der 50. US-Bundesstaat -
und für mich der 50. Staat,
den ich besuche.
Ein Traum wird wahr auf Maui,
der Trauminsel.
Passt perfekt. Auch weil das fast
schon eine Pilgerreise für mich ist:
Auf Hawaii
liegen die Wurzeln der Subkultur,
die mein Leben bis heute prägt.
Surfen ist die Mutter
aller Brettsportarten,
inklusive Skateboarding.
Und da hat ausgerechnet ein Schweizer
sich hier einen Namen gemacht:
Jucker Hawaii.
Einen sehr schweizerischen Namen.
13.30 Uhr -
Schweizer sind pünktlich.
Mike Jucker, Skateboard-Hersteller.
Klar, muss ich den kennenlernen.
Sieht schon mal freundlich aus.
# Viva ...
I'll be talking with these people.
These people. Aloha!
Grüezi.
- Bist du Mike?
Ja. Und du bist Arthur.
Freut mich, hallo!
Ich muss noch den Junior
bei der Mutter abgeben.
Alright Mister,
your Mom is waiting down there.
Also, kommt rauf!
Schau dir das an!
Das ist ja geil.
Sehr cool.
Da war anfangs alles leer.
Nur der Boden war drin.
Nach und nach
habe ich das eingerichtet.
Wir sind ja zu dir gekommen,
weil ich gehört habe,
dass es hier einen Mike Jucker gibt,
einen Schweizer, der einen
Skateladen - ein Skate-Brand hat!
Du lebst den Traum!
Ja! Ich muss mich auch fast täglich
in den Arm kneifen.
Ich kann sagen, in den 16 Jahren
ist kein einziger Tag vergangen,
an dem ich nicht mindestens
einmal gedacht habe:
"Wow, ich wohne immer noch hier,
ich bin noch nicht
aus dem Traum erwacht."
Das ist wirklich so.
Es ist echt sehr schön hier.
Ich bin ein "Brettlibub"
seit ich denken kann.
Und die sind alle von dir?
Nicht alle. Das ist ein Brett,
das wir in Zusammenarbeit
mit einer Künstlerin aus Deutschland
gemacht haben.
Das hier ist ein Retro-Brett.
Das kennst du bestimmt auch noch.
Ich bin noch einer von damals ...
Das ist so ein Retro-Board.
Auch die Graphics.
- Ja, cool, oder?
Warum bist du ursprünglich
nach Hawaii gekommen?
Was bringt einen Zürcher
hierher nach Maui?
Ich war ein Skate- und Snowboarder
und bin in den 90er-Jahren
Swiss Cup gefahren.
Surfen war für mich
der ultimative Traum.
Ich hatte das Glück, zwei Jahre
in der Welt herumzureisen,
als Gepäck zwei Surfbretter
und ein Rucksack.
Ich ging zu den Surfspots
dieser Welt und surfte und hoffte,
dass ich das so lange wie möglich
durchziehen kann.
Meine eigene Herausforderung war:
so lange wie möglich nicht in
die Schweiz zurückkehren zu müssen.
Während meinen Reisen habe ich dann
meine zukünftige Frau kennengelernt,
auch eher
aus einem regnerischen Ort der USA.
Wir wollten es in Maui zu probieren.
2002 lagen hier die Jobs
auf der Strasse.
* Skate-Punk-Song:
"I miss you" von Blink 182 *
Die Boards, die Mike heute designt,
verkauft er nicht primär auf Hawaii,
aber er verkauft sie dank Hawaii.
Aus Marketingsicht
ist dieser Ort unschlagbar:
Wo Hawaii draufsteht,
steckt der Aloha-Lifestyle drin.
Und das zieht.
Solche Boards gefallen mir.
Dieses hier haben wir lokal gemacht.
Damit sammeln wir Geld
für die Save Honolua Coalition,
das ist eine Umweltorganisation.
Ich mache ja Business
mit dem Wort Hawaii.
Ich ziehe einen Nutzen
aus diesem Wort.
Es ist ein guter Brand.
- Hawaii ist ein sehr guter Brand.
Deshalb fühle ich mich verpflichtet,
und das ist auch
eine hawaiianische Tradition:
"You give back where you take from."
Also nicht nur Nehmen,
sondern auch Geben. - Absolut.
Longboards sind etwas für Leute,
die gern einfach so
durch die Gegend cruisen.
So ein Teil habe ich noch nicht.
Zeit also, eins auszuprobieren.
Ich gebe dir eine Auswahl.
Das hier ist der Pau Hana Cruiser.
Yeah, Pau Hana - Schluss mit Arbeit.
Dann gibt es noch zwei, drei andere
da unten beim Eingang.
Longboards sind schon dein Ding ...
- Ja.
Das musst du mir jetzt
etwas beibringen,
denn ich komme ja vom Pushen
und vom kleinen Brett.
Alrighty.
Das sind jetzt
ganz verschiedene shapes.
Damit kann man weniger pushen.
Siehst du, ich schaff die Kurve
nicht einmal mehr.
Whoa!
- Siehst du, was ich meine?
Ich habe gesehen, was du meinst.
Authentischer geht es nicht.
Du musst einfach diese Surf-,
diese Pumpbewegung machen.
Du wirst sehen,
das wird automatisch ...
Da siehst du,
der hat es schon kapiert.
Ciao.
Beim Skaten gehört es dazu,
sich von den Locals
die besten Spots zeigen zu lassen.
Produzentin Lisa
ist wenig begeistert.
Ein Knochenbruch
und unser Dreh ist futsch.
Aber ein paar Runs
müssen jetzt einfach sein.
Let's go to the ditch.
Boys will be boys.
* Skate-Punk-Song:
"Back in the USA" von Green Day *
# Let freedom ring
with all the crazies on parade.
Ein Ditch, wie im Film.
Wie im Skate-Film.
# Let them eat poison
and it tastes like lemonade.
Das war knapp.
Etwas geht mir
nicht mehr aus dem Kopf:
Zurückgeben an die Gemeinschaft,
hat Mike gesagt,
das sei hawaiianisch;
der Aloha Spirit.
Das Wort begegnet einem hier überall:
Es heisst Hallo, Auf Wiedersehen -
und irgendwie auch alles dazwischen.
Aber was bedeutet Aloha wirklich?
Wir suchen die Antwort beim
traditionellen Volksfest, dem Luau.
Stefan, ganz der Einheimische,
sorgt dafür, dass mein Outfit stimmt.
Ziemlich cool.
Du kannst wählen,
ob du es tragen willst oder nicht.
Hoffentlich stimmt die Grösse.
Was meinst du? Ein bisschen leger.
Und das trägt man für einen Luau?
Du kannst am Luau
damit nicht falsch liegen.
Wer weiss, vielleicht
hilft das Blumenmuster ja dabei,
dem Spirit näherzukommen.
One, two, three, tap.
- Tap.
Ganz sicher hilft es, wenn ich
ein paar Schritte Hula lerne.
Step, boom.
Step, boom!
Bring your feet closer together
so you can pop out your legs.
Step - lift up!
Step, boom.
- Step, boom.
One, two, three!
Du hast eben
den Wehe-Schwung gemacht.
Der Wehe ist echt schwierig.
Kawika Frietes ist Zeremonienmeister
beim Old Lahaina Luau,
einer Kultur-Show, die auf Maui
als beste ihrer Art gilt.
Die Hawaiianer
leben ein Leben in Gastfreundschaft.
Du wirst das heute Abend erleben.
Die Angestellten hier
leben den Aloha Spirit.
Ich denke,
bezüglich Gastfreundschaft
schlagen wir sogar
unsere südpazifischen Cousins.
Wirklich?
Sie erwähnten den Aloha Spirit.
Ich höre oft davon.
Was heisst er für Sie?
Was wird damit umschrieben?
Für mich heisst Aloha, etwas zu tun,
ohne im Gegenzug
etwas dafür zu erwarten.
Du tust Gutes,
du tust das Richtige.
Menschen willkommen heissen,
sie bewirten,
sie als Teil einer Familie
betrachten.
Genau das machen wir hier.
Aber heutzutage ist Aloha
doch auch viel Business, oder?
Aloha ist überall!
Es ist  d i e  Marke für Hawaii.
Richtig.
Ich möchte jetzt etwas sagen, aber
ich kann nicht, es ist politisch.
Doch, doch,
das wird nur in Europa ausgestrahlt.
Jemand hat versucht,
das Wort Aloha zu patentieren.
Das kam nicht gut an
bei den Wächtern unserer Kultur.
Das muss für alle
zugänglich bleiben.
Genau.
Der Abend rückt näher,
und damit Showtime in Lahaina.
Mai Tai, Sir?
- Yes, sure.
Yes, go ahead.
Let's get you a lei. Aloha, welcome.
- Thank you.
500 Gäste, Abend für Abend,
praktisch immer ausverkauft.
Ich sage ja: Aloha zieht.
Um die 3 Mio. Touristen
besuchen Maui pro Jahr.
Das sind 20 Mal mehr Menschen
als hier leben.
Das kulinarische Highlight
wird gross inszeniert:
Es gibt Schwein aus dem Erdofen.
Der Holzgeruch geht ins Fleisch,
das gibt einen richtig
guten Geschmack.
Alle warten, bis das tote Tier
aus dem Erdreich genommen wird.
Mmmh ...
Dabei esse ich gar kein Fleisch.
Kennst du das?
Wir machen das in Houston ständig,
Mann.
Really? In Houston?
One, two, tree!
Schwein wird heute Abend
der Hauptgang für Hunderte sein.
Nicht für mich. Ich esse Fisch.
* Hawaiianische Musik *
Alte hawaiianische Bräuche
hin oder her:
Dass wir hier in den USA sind,
zeigt sich am perfekten Showbiz.
Und am selbstverständlichen
Small Talk.
Dieses Bier wird auf Hawaii gebraut,
oder?
Ja, speziell für den Lahaina Luau.
Weisst du, was witzig ist?
In Deutschland
gibt es ein altes Lied mit dem Titel
"Es gibt kein Bier auf Hawaii".
Es gibt echt Leute, die glauben,
es gäbe kein Bier auf Hawaii.
Das ist verrückt!
Wir haben eine eigene Brauerei hier!
Enjoy!
- Cheers.
# ... und nur vom Hula Hula
geht der Durst nicht weg.
* Schnelle Trommelschläge *
Am nächsten Morgen
wage ich mich mal allein aufs Brett.
Jeder Versuch zählt.
Die Bedingungen
sind aber nicht eben ideal.
Es ist windig,
richtige Wellen aber gibt es kaum.
Und Wasser mag ich immer noch nicht,
auch wenn es 27 °C warm ist.
* Hawaiianische Musik *
So ganz allein,
ich Alpenmann im Ozean,
ohne Ahnung von der Brandung.
Ne, da wird nix draus.
Wird wohl nix.
Ich kann's nicht lesen.
Ich sehe nicht, welche Wellen
gross sind, wo sie brechen usw.
Die Erfahrung fehlt einfach.
Du denkst: "Okay, die könnte es sein,
oder vielleicht die, oder die dort."
Immerhin bin ich zurückgekommen.
Hawaii,
das heisst auf deutsch Urlaub.
Das stimmt zwar nicht,
trifft die Sache aber ziemlich genau.
Strand, Sonne, Palmen - so zeichnen
schon Kinder das Paradies.
Und genau wie im Garten Eden
wächst hier jede süsse Frucht.
Biobauern
lieben die fruchtbare Erde hier,
und die hippe Kundschaft sucht
die Natürlichkeit, die daraus wächst.
Was ist das?
Weisse Sapote.
Das wächst alles hier?
Ja.
- Wow!
Gibt es etwas,
das hier nicht wächst?
Nein, alles.
Das hier auch.
Das macht 21 $.
That's what I call a six-pack.
Das Paradies gehört indes
nicht Kleinbauern allein:
Hawaii ist auch ein Eldorado
für Agrochemie-Konzerne.
Die lieben die fruchtbare Erde
ebenfalls.
Auf Maui ist allen voran
Monsanto präsent,
ein Global Player im Business
mit Gentech-Saatgut und Pestiziden.
Und einer der umstrittensten Multis
überhaupt.
Nach hartnäckigem Nachfragen
haben wir einen Termin bekommen.
Der Konzern
steht stark unter Beschuss.
Kurz vor meinem Besuch
hat ein kalifornisches Gericht rund
80 Mio. $ Schadenersatz gesprochen.
Der Grund: Ein Monsanto-Produkt
habe beim Kläger Krebs verursacht.
Das hier ist es. Private road.
Gut bewacht.
Ich heisse Kay.
- Ich bin Arthur.
Dan. Freut mich.
- Meinerseits.
Sind Sie das erste Mal auf Hawaii?
Ja. Und es ist der 50. Bundesstaat,
den ich besuche.
Dan Clegg
ist Chef von Monsanto Hawaii.
Seit Sommer 2018 gehört die Firma
dem Bayer-Konzern aus Lerverkusen,
der hier punkto Gentech
ein freundlicheres Umfeld antrifft
als in Europa.
Ihr könnt da drüben parken.
Dann treffen wir uns bei den Bänken
und reden ein bisschen,
bevor wir ins Feld gehen.
- Okay.
Imagine Hawaii ...
Ich bin ja mal gespannt,
wie man bei Monsanto
den Geist von Aloha definiert.
Wir geben vor der Tour für alle
Gäste Sicherheitsinstruktionen.
Ja, Sicherheit ist wichtig.
Unser grösstes Anliegen auf der Farm
ist Sicherheit.
Falls irgendetwas passiert,
ihr einen Kratzer habt
oder sonst irgendetwas,
dann sagt uns das bitte.
Bleibt in unserer Nähe,
wenn wir auf dem Feld sind.
Bitte seid vorsichtig,
wenn ihr aus dem Bus steigt.
Ich werde an eurer Seite sein, weil
es da draussen sehr steinig ist.
Ist jemand auf Bienen allergisch?
Ich, äh, ich glaube nicht.
Ich frage, weil ich
keine Medikamente dabei habe.
Wir werden in ein Feld
mit vielen Blumen gehen.
Da gibt es manchmal Probleme
mit Bienen- und Wespenstichen.
Wir nehmen den Bus M 21.
Wir zeigen euch
nicht die ganze Farm,
sondern wir konzentrieren uns
darauf,
was ihr praktisch
auf all unseren Farmen sehen würdet.
Eine gute Auswahl also.
Monsanto testet auf Maui
Gentech-Mais,
die Samen werden dann patentiert.
Dan führt mich zuerst auf ein Feld,
wo Pflanzen gerade wild wuchern -
zur Bodenerholung.
Das Klima auf Hawaii erlaubt jedoch
drei bis vier Ernten im Jahr,
das spart Zeit.
Und Zeit ist Geld, klar.
Die hier entwickelten Samen
sollen resistent sein
gegen Schädlinge
und steigende Temperaturen.
Es gibt Länder wie die USA,
die offener sind bezüglich
gentechnisch veränderten Pflanzen,
im Gegensatz zu Europa,
das dieser Technik
eher skeptisch gegenübersteht.
Denken Sie, das wird sich ändern?
Ich glaube, es geht um Bildung.
Die Wissenschaft
verändert sich schneller,
als die Leute mithalten können.
Leuten, die in der Biologiestunde
eingeschlafen sind,
ist schwierig zu erklären,
wie Biotechnologie funktioniert.
Es ist auch kompliziert.
Menschen entscheiden
aufgrund ihres Bauchgefühls.
Und es ist ihr Recht, zu wählen,
was sie essen wollen.
Ich finde, es braucht alle.
Wir müssen alle mit einbeziehen
und wenn es Fragen gibt,
lasst uns richtig darüber reden.
200 Leute arbeiten auf Maui
für Monsanto,
auf ganz Hawaii sind es 600.
Ich passe auf. Versprochen!
Okay.
Wir stellen euch jetzt dem Team vor.
Tim, Michelle.
Good morning.
- Hi guys!
Guten Morgen.
- Tim Stevens.
Michelle Starke.
Ich mag, wie ihr alle diese Hemden
trägt. Richtig hawaiianisch.
Aloha kommt von innen.
Stimmt. Aber viele denken, dass man
bei Monsanto Schutzanzüge trägt.
Macht ihr das nicht?
Nein.
Aber ihr müsst euch
hin und wieder schützen,
wenn ihr sprayt usw.?
Es gibt immer
Regeln und Vorschriften.
Diese Regeln befolgen wir.
Die Regel heute ist: Hawaii-Shirt.
Die Regel heute ist:
Hawaii-Shirt und gut darin aussehen.
Okay.
- Wir besorgen dir eins.
Ich hab schon beim Luau
eins getragen.
Diese Samen
haben die gewünschten Merkmale,
z.B. Resistenz
gegen eine bestimmte Krankheit.
Ihr habt sie also schon so weit
entwickelt, wie ihr sie wollt?
Ja. Wir pflanzen sie dann
in diese Saatgefässe.
Nach zehn Tagen haben wir das hier.
In zehn Tagen?
- Ja.
Die wachsen tatsächlich schnell.
Und am Schluss
sind sie dann so gross?
Ja.
Wow. Und wie lange dauert das?
Ungefähr drei Monate.
Drei Monate? Wow!
Michelle zeigt mir, wie die kon-
trollierte Befruchtung funktioniert.
Ich bin drum im Bio-Unterricht
auch manchmal eingeschlafen.
Am Morgen nimmst du diesen Beutel
und tust es drauf.
So funktioniert die Bestäubung.
Handbestäubung heisst das.
Passiert hier 4,5 Mio. Mal pro Jahr.
Das Überleben der Menschen
hängt davon ab,
dass jemand gewillt ist,
diese Dinge zu tun.
Das ist es also,
was Ihnen Ihre Arbeit bedeutet?
Das Herz fühlt so.
Der Aloha Spirit?
Ja, es ist etwas sehr Persönliches.
Können wir hier rein?
- Nein.
We can't go in here?
Die Treibhäuser sind für uns tabu.
Stattdessen zeigt uns Tim
die Maschine,
mit der die Erde
für die Setzlinge präpariert wird.
Sieht wie eine Zigarre aus.
- Eine dicke Erdwurst.
Wir entwickeln diesen Samen
über mehrere Generationen weiter,
sammeln dabei Daten
und werten sie dann aus.
Stellen Sie sich das hier nicht
als ein Experimentierlabor vor,
sondern eher
als einen Ort der Samenproduktion.
Und das Ziel wäre dann,
Pestizide verwenden zu können,
ohne die Pflanzen zu schädigen?
Das ist eines unserer Produkte.
Die Konsumenten
wollen bessere Produkte,
die besser für die Umwelt sind
und weniger Zeug brauchen.
Und Bauern brauchen Rendite.
Es ist schwierig, das alles
unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Weniger Zeug,
also weniger Pestizide und so?
Weniger von allem.
Aber das ist ja die Hauptkritik,
dass hier mehr gespritzt wird,
wegen der häufigen Ernten.
Unser Ziel ist: weniger von allem.
Weniger von allem? Ausser Profit.
Ihr seid ja gross
im Herbizidgeschäft.
Eine Pflanze zu haben, die gegen ein
bestimmtes Herbizid resistent ist,
macht Sinn.
Dann kann Monsanto beides verkaufen.
Es ist kein Geheimnis:
Unser Job ist, Geld zu verdienen.
Dafür seid ihr bekannt.
Alle haben eigene Bedürfnisse.
Es ist herausfordernd.
Ich verstehe.
Können wir auch aufs Feld?
Das ist alles,
was wir für euch haben.
That's all?
Das ist die Tour.
- Okay.
Thank you, Dan.
- Es war uns ein Vergnügen.
Thanks for showing us this.
Naja, so richtig entspannt
verlief dieser Besuch nicht.
Als Gentech-Gigant muss sich Monsanto
ja einiges anhören rund um die Welt.
In Hawaii ist der Widerstand
aber auch sehr lokal.
Sie scheinen hier
nicht beliebt zu sein.
GMO, also genveränderte Pflanzen,
das passt in den Augen vieler
Einheimischer so gar nicht zu Aloha.
Ich treffe gleich
einen Wortführer des Protests,
der das Agrochemie-Business
auf Maui erschüttert hat.
Alika Atay ist Politiker,
ehemaliger Biobauer und jemand,
der bereit ist zu kämpfen für
das Erbe seiner hawaiianischen Ahnen.
Hallo, ich bin Arthur.
Schön, Sie kennenzulernen.
Hallo.
Ich habe
ein paar Videos von Ihnen gesehen.
Sie sind sehr bekannt.
Ich habe mich immer an das Konzept
von Aloha Aina gehalten.
Aloha Aina bedeutet Liebe zum Land.
Früher waren wir für das Überleben
abhängig vom Sammeln.
Deshalb wussten wir
über die Jahreszeiten
und den Zyklus der einzelnen
Pflanzen genau Bescheid.
Wir wussten, jetzt ist Blütezeit,
jetzt ist Erntezeit.
Und man ging hin und pflückte einfach
die Früchte, die es gab?
Ja. Auch in Bezug auf das Meer
und die Buchten.
Wir wussten,
woher der Wind und die Wellen kamen.
Ich gehöre zu jener Generation.
Vor vier Jahren
spaltete eine Abstimmung die Insel:
Eine knappe Mehrheit sagte damals Ja
zu einem Moratorium
für genveränderte Pflanzen.
Ein Gericht hob die Entscheidung
danach zwar auf,
doch der Unmut ist geblieben.
Alika will mir einen befreundeten
Biobauern vorstellen.
Der Weg zu ihm führt vorbei
an den Ruinen einer Zuckerfabrik.
Keine Chance auf dem Weltmarkt.
Die Zeiten, als Zucker Gold wert war
auf Maui, sind Geschichte.
Alright.
Also, zur Info:
Hier beginnt die Farm.
Und was baust du hier an?
Früher war hier auf dem ganzen Land
Zuckerrohr.
Im Grunde eine Monokultur.
Es war eine Monokultur.
Während 144 Jahren gab es nur Ananas
und Zuckerrohr auf diesem Boden.
For 144 years.
Und du versuchst nun,
dieses irgendwie missbrauchte Land
sinnvoll zu nutzen?
Ja, unsere Mission ist es, wieder
Leben in den Boden zu bringen.
Wenn man in der Erde kein Leben hat,
hat man einfach nur Dreck.
Bobby Pahia, genannt Uncle Bobby,
sät statt Monokulturen
lieber Pflanzen mit Kultur:
Kalo z.B.,
die hawaiianische Urknolle.
Das ist Kalo.
Und heute gibt es
wieder mehr Menschen, die Kalo essen?
Immer mehr.
Aber leider ist Kalo und
der sog. Poi, den man daraus macht,
für die Leute auf Hawaii
zu einem Luxusgut geworden.
Was mal ein Grundnahrungsmittel war,
ist also nun ein Luxusgut.
Richtig.
Das ist für dich.
Wisst ihr, es gibt in der Schweiz
diese Tradition:
Wenn der Reporter etwas bekommt,
dann gibt er es direkt
an seine Produzentin weiter.
Damit kann ich
mein Hotelzimmer verschönern.
Agrarland ist knapp auf Maui.
Statt Gentech-Produkte sollten hier
einheimische Sorten angebaut werden,
findet Uncle Bobby.
Die Insel
soll sich selbst versorgen können.
Heute muss Hawaii,
das grüne Paradies,
90 % der Lebensmittel importieren.
Das sind Schweine,
die ich für den Lahaina Luau züchte.
Ah, da waren wir gestern.
Das sind sie.
Wir werden ihnen jetzt
nicht erzählen, wie sie enden.
Tolle Party!
Ihr werdet sie aber nicht mögen.
Wir machen hier
eine bestimmte Form von Weidepflege.
Wir bringen viele Schweine auf eine
kleine Fläche und lassen sie düngen.
Dadurch brauche ich keinen
künstlichen Dünger mehr.
Wir wollen versuchen,
überhaupt nichts mehr zuzuführen.
Ihr wollt
die ursprüngliche Erde zurück.
Wie im Wald.
Der Wald ist unser Lehrer.
Wenn du in den Wald gehst,
siehst du keine Monokulturen.
Es geht um Werte oder Geld.
Will man den kurzfristigen Gewinn,
setzt man aufs Geld.
Das Land ist dabei unwichtig,
weil es nur darum geht,
die Ernte zu steigern.
Das müssen viele Bauern so machen,
oder?
Fast die ganze Welt tut das.
- Ja.
Wir wollen davon wegkommen.
Wenn Alika mich fragt, kann ich ihm
direkt in die Augen schauen
und sagen: "Ja, ich mache Aloha Aina
und ich mache Malama Aina."
Wir mussten diese Erfahrung
mit Chemikalien und Pestiziden
durchmachen,
die weder gut sind für den Boden
noch gut für die Tiere,
noch gut für die Menschen.
Ein geschlossener Kreislauf aber
kann nur mit Aloha erreicht werden,
Liebe. Und mit Aina.
Dann haben wir Aloha Aina.
Die Liebe zum Land.
- Ja.
Der Respekt. Das Gewissen auch.
Malama heisst achtgeben.
Aloha Aina ist die Liebe zum Land.
Und Malama Aina heisst,
sich um das Land kümmern.
Malama Honua dann,
sich um Mutter Erde kümmern.
* Grunzen *
* Sanfte Musik *
Aloha, das ist mehr als alles andere
eine Lebenseinstellung.
Und das spüren wir hier besonders:
Das Dorf Paia an der Nordküste
zieht mit seinem Surfer-Vibe
Aussteiger aus aller Welt an.
Ich frage mal einfach drauflos,
was Aloha für sie bedeutet.
Hey, wie gehts?
- Pretty good.
Wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm.
Wir kommen aus der Schweiz.
Um was geht es im Film?
Es geht um den Aloha Spirit.
Wir wollen herausfinden,
was Aloha heisst.
Liebe ist bedingungslos,
das ist die Bedeutung von Aloha.
Übersetzt heisst es,
den Atem teilen.
Wie wenn du also
mit jemand anderem gemeinsam atmest.
Oder wie durch eine andere Person
als Individuum existieren.
Also im selben Rhythmus
mit den anderen leben.
Das ist die wörtliche Übersetzung?
Ja.
- Das wusste ich nicht.
Es geht um Liebe.
Aber worüber ich wirklich sprechen
möchte, ist der Kalender der Maya.
Darüber lehre ich.
Bitte rückt ab
vom Kalender des Papstes
und kehrt
zur natürlichen Zeit zurück!
Diese umfasst 13 Monate
mit je 28 Tagen.
Das ist die natürliche Zeit,
wie Gott sie kreiert hat.
Das ist meine kurze Botschaft.
Ich würde gerne
vom Kalender wegkommen,
einfach um mehr frei zu haben.
Vielen Dank.
Es ist etwas, das in Gefahr ist.
In Gefahr? Warum das?
Weil es viele Leute gibt, die
den Geist der Insel nicht verstehen.
Sie kommen
und folgen ihren eigenen Interessen.
Immobilienleute, Monsanto.
Bayer jetzt.
Aloha Spirit
kann verschiedene Bedeutungen haben.
V.a. Pono,
das heisst, das Richtige tun.
Man soll nicht Angst haben,
ein Lächeln zu verschenken
oder jemanden zu umarmen oder auf
der Strasse zu helfen. Pono eben.
Die Leute lächeln tatsächlich.
Das ist nicht überall so.
Das ist schön.
Paia ist eine der coolsten Städte
der Welt.
Alle lächeln,
wenn sie hierher kommen.
Gut. Also viel Pono
und happy Thanksgiving.
Aloha.
- Aloha.
It's pretty cool.
Gleich bei Paia um die Ecke
liegt Ho'okipa Beach,
d e r  Surf-Spot auf Maui.
Eigentlich Hoheitsgebiet derjenigen,
die es wirklich draufhaben.
Hallo!
Kommt ihr jeden Tag hierher?
Da draussen
sind ein paar echte Profis.
Unglaublich,
wir haben sie gerade beobachtet.
Was macht ihr hier?
Wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm
über Maui.
Oh, nein. Worüber?
- Über Maui.
Bringst du die Massen rein?
- Ich? Ne.
Sag ihm, wie teuer es hier ist.
Zeig es nicht zu einladend!
Okay, nein, es ist schrecklich hier.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass Hawaii
an sich schon ein Paradies wäre.
Woher kommst du?
- Aus der Schweiz.
Da soll es auch nett sein.
- Das stimmt.
Ich habe Fotos gesehen.
Ja, es ist ein Binnenland.
Wir können nicht surfen.
Aber ihr habt Schnee, stimmt's?
- Ja, tonnenweise.
Das ist der Ausgleich.
Schnee, das ist mein Element.
Die Brandung von Ho'okipa
ist es nicht.
Mit Dustin
wage ich mich trotzdem rein.
Ich nenne es meine rote Rakete.
Cool.
Es ist schnell und wendig,
eine gute Mischung
zwischen langem und kurzem Brett.
Wir suchen einen Strandabschnitt,
wo wir den Profis nicht im Weg sind.
Ich hoffe, dass die Wellen dort
nicht ganz so hoch sind.
Hoffentlich schaffst du es,
das Brett zu lenken.
Dein Ziel heute ist,
die Kontrolle zu behalten
und auf den Wellen zu kurven.
Du bist jetzt an der Nordküste.
- Yeah, well, that's cool.
Ich würde gerne länger hier bleiben
und ...
... und besser werden.
Das wollen alle: Nach Hawaii ziehen
und surfen lernen.
Bereit?
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
hierher zu kommen.
Aber mit dir fühle ich mich sicher.
So sicher man sich halt fühlen kann,
dem wilden Wasser ausgesetzt.
Da fliehen sogar Profischwimmer.
Für mich gibt's jetzt aber
nur die Flucht nach vorn.
Die Wellen sind zu hoch,
um durchzupaddeln.
Darum habe ich
die Turtle Roll gelernt:
auf den Rücken, Luft anhalten,
unten durch.
Aber eigentlich will ich ja
obendrauf stehen, so wie Dustin.
Wozu ich erst mal aufstehen müsste.
Fast 2 Std. schlucke ich Wasser
und paddle mir die Arme ab.
Aber ein paar Sekunden Aloha
sind es wert.
Super gemacht! Das war harte Arbeit.
Das war es.
Einige hast du gut erwischt!
Danke, dass du mich
am Leben gehalten hast.
Du hast es allein geschafft.
Sogar Schweizer Männer können
surfen wie ein Maui Surfer Girl.
Wieso hast du dein Geschäft
eigentlich auf Frauen ausgerichtet?
Eine Nische für Frauen ist wichtig.
Surfen kann ein stark
männlich dominierter Sport sein.
Es kann sehr einschüchternd sein,
wenn du so eine Reihe siehst
mit Männern,
die sich so voll reinstürzen.
Frauen bringen
einen anmutigen Aspekt rein.
Männer können
viel mit ihren Muskeln machen,
aber Surfen ist voller Anmut.
Als eine der ersten Frauen
hat Dustin auch die berüchtigtste
Welle von Hawaii bezwungen: Jaws.
Als ich auf dieser Welle war,
fühlte ich völlige Ruhe,
obwohl es das schrecklichste Ding
war, das ich je gesehen habe.
Aber ich liebe es, das Adrenalin zu
spüren und völlig präsent zu sein.
Völlig präsent - das vereint
uns Surfer, Skater, Snowboarder:
Der Moment ist alles, was zählt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Viel Zeit bleibt uns nicht mehr
auf Maui.
Zum mythischen Städtchen Hana aber
müssen wir unbedingt,
das hören wir von allen Seiten.
Erreichbar ist es
nur über eine Dschungelstrasse.
In Hana soll der wahre Geist
von Hawaii überlebt haben.
Und tatsächlich:
Ohne es geplant zu haben, finde ich
mich an einer Veranstaltung wieder,
an der wir die einzigen
Nicht-Hawaiianer sind.
Es ist der Tag der Makahiki-Spiele.
Hallo, ich bin Arthur.
Wir haben gehört,
dass man hierher kommen muss.
Makahiki - was spielt ihr hier?
Das ist Moa Pahe'e.
Man muss zwischen die Stäbe treffen.
Tai weiss, wovon er spricht:
Er war der erste,
der diese Wettkämpfe gewonnen hat.
Die Makahiki-Spiele sind so etwas
wie die Olympischen Spiele
von Hawaii.
Wirklich?
Es ist eine grosse Ehre,
den Championtitel zu erhalten,
den Ano Koa Kiekie.
Dann kannst du mit
herausgestreckter Brust herumgehen.
You can walk tall.
- Yeah.
Like a rock.
- Right.
Tai stellt uns den Organisator
der Spiele vor und ich merke:
Sie sind auch
ein politisches Statement.
Willkommen in unserem Land!
- Thank you.
Wir feiern heute La Ku'oko'a,
den Unabhängigkeitstag
der hawaiianischen Nation.
Unser Land wurde 1893 ins Exil
getrieben von unseren Freunden,
den Amerikanern,
und ihren Geschäftsinteressen.
Arbeitest du morgen?
Nein,
morgen ist mein 27. Geburtstag.
Have a good birthday party tomorrow.
That's good, yeah.
Wenn ich sage,
willkommen in meinem Land,
meine ich das Königreich Hawaii.
Obwohl viele denken,
dass hier Amerika ist,
kann das niemand belegen.
Geh mal ins Justizministerium!
Die können dir nicht sagen,
wie sie Hawaii erworben haben.
Wenn Sie mich fragen,
sind Sie heute der König von Hawaii.
Mein einziger König
ist Jesus Christus.
Ich bin nur
gewählter Vertreter meines Bezirks.
Thank you.
- Thank you, folks.
Gibt es da ein Geheimnis,
eine bestimmte Technik?
Falls du es herausfindest,
sagst du es mir?
Das war knapp.
Du bist Hawaiianerin?
- Ja.
Dann ist das auch Teil deiner Kultur?
Ist es wichtig, an solchen Anlässen
seine Erbe zu feiern?
Unbedingt. Es ist wie bei allen,
die ihre Kultur feiern.
Es ist also etwas Eigenes und nicht
unbedingt gegen die USA gerichtet?
Wir sind nicht gegen irgendetwas.
Wir sind einfach für Hawaii.
Wie kann man nicht für Hawaii sein?
Ich weiss.
Wir haben Strand, gutes Essen ...
Und ihr habt Aloha.
Und wir haben Aloha.
Das wird nie ausgehen.
Bevor Hawaii 1959
den USA als 50. Staat beitrat,
wurden die Inseln
als US-Territorium betrachtet,
lokale Sprache und Kultur
unterdrückt.
Nichts als das Gras berührt.
Danke, du hast mir Glück gebracht.
Im alten Hawaii gab es eine Zeit
für Krieg und eine Zeit für Frieden,
erzählt man mir.
In Friedenszeiten erfolgte das
Kräftemessen an Spielen wie diesen.
Die Makahiki-Wettkämpfe hier in Hana
finden erst zum vierten Mal statt.
Bist du immer noch im Spiel?
- Ja.
Und wie sieht's aus?
- Ich bin immer noch dabei.
Es gibt nur einen ersten Champion.
- Ich werde immer der erste bleiben.
Viel Glück dieses Jahr.
- Vielen Dank.
Der Tag in Hana hat mir gezeigt,
wie wichtig den Hawaiianern
ihre Eigenständigkeit ist,
gelebt in Spiel und Spass.
Friedenszeiten - ganz eindeutig.
* Hawaiianische Musik *
Zum Schluss zieht es mich noch einmal
zu den Surfern von Ho'okipa Beach.
* Hawaiianische Musik *
Ich finde es halt einfach
wahnsinnig faszinierend.
Man kann es sich tausendmal,
eine Million Mal anschauen.
Es hat so eine Leichtigkeit,
so eine Grazie mit den Elementen.
Davon kriegt man, glaube ich,
nie genug.
Hat das was mit Aloha Spirit zu tun?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Also es geht ja auch darum,
dass man ein bisschen loslässt,
dass man nichts erzwingt.
Und beim Surfen geht's auch darum,
zu warten,
auf die Welle, die dann richtig ist,
und sich der dann ein Stück weit
auch hinzugeben.
* Hawaiianische Musik *